i i'm salivating too  because i'm just getting warmed up  you know conor mcgregor has a lot more  to focus on besides me right now i'm  five wins in a row  he's  one in three in the past four years  so a guy needs to get off of his uh  little vodka or whatever the [ __ ] his  brand is and and uh sober up and start  to get back in the [ __ ] gym and then  we can [ __ ] fight but to be honest  no way he hits harder than woodley  he doesn't weigh as much as woodley  he's shorter than woodley  i said it before the fight i think  woodley's a harder fight than him  especially especially on the weight  where he's going  he's going counters going down i'm going  up woodley came in game